I apologize in advance for my voice. I am getting a little cold. Okay, let's get started. Reminder to
look at the members' site for all analysis, all these changes in the laws that are attacking
clinics like ours. This is very frustrating for us. I cannot begin to tell you how frustrating we are.
Well, we just trust in the sovereignty of God and know that he's got to play it on this,
that we're going to be able to even help want people, hopefully. So please look at that for the
adults, spend some of the new legal things that are happy to keep us doing everything over Zoom.
We don't have any options. Obviously we're closed on Monday. I do want to add a new protocol,
only really at Zoom call, we're just discussing possible changes to protocol,
and probably won't do that till maybe the end of January or February. But I want to know what days
and times you guys would like for that. So please let me know if you want to do that. I don't know,
maybe just this webinar. This Zoom call is just fine. Another reminder that you can be showing
all our courses at any time you want. I use the same login as you do for the member site,
same username and password. The first question is this one. It's just said information on Cakexia.
So this is the homepage. I just took a screenshot of the homepage, this right here,
of the members holy site. And this is what you have access to how you access this in call right now.
We've moved all our blog that used to be on our website is now only accessible through your private
membership. So you, the members of our, you know, our protocol patients, but we can't use that
term anymore. This isn't the legality. It's going on. We practice some far more medicine here.
We pulled all our blog off of the web, beating the public web. So public can't see our blog unless
they do exactly the web address to get to it. So it's not on our website anymore. It's all on this site.
So there's some, we're doing a lot of updates to them. There's some, some old information,
some of the blogs I wrote five, six, seven, eight years ago. So we're going through an updating
850 blog posts. But we're trying to make it relevant for you guys today. How do you get to
information on Cakexia or information on, you know, a Roman taste of kivotures or information of
whatever you're looking for? On the member site, go to that little thing right there. Click on it. I can't
click on it. This is just a screenshot. Click on that thing right there. And then you can put it
in whatever term you want. And it'll take you to somewhere on the site or the blog that has that.
So if it doesn't take you to anything, I don't have anything on it. But I have several articles
on Cakexia and one of the things you could do for Cakexia and healthy gain weight with your losing weight.
So anything that you need to search for start with that, I know it is who it is that wrote this
question. So I'm going to answer it personally. And this is how you guys can ask questions. You can
ask questions. And if it is really a personal question that I will look up that person's
plan and their protocol and everything. So we'll be reading sort of how to understand it. You have a
lot of my recent test information, Dutch test, thermography, done in December, blood work,
much of which I don't understand as it applies to my condition. I just need your opinion on whether I
need to make changes or continue with what I have been doing. So this is the real question right here.
I just needed to know. So the answer to that question is you recorded, I looked at all those all
that data and I think you should just stay on what you are doing. Don't make any changes based
upon that information that you're setting. Second question is I was also wondered about doing
a breast ultrasound coming up in February. Haven't done one per seven months since the last one.
Yeah, I think that would be a good idea. This person was doing breast ultrasound. I think every three
months that we pushed them on to every six months or so. I think it would be a good idea. Yep.
I think that would be a good plan to get that ultrasound done. All right. Next question I'm taking.
I have erected an infant bed as all. Passing what I think is parasites. This person sent me
pictures too. While doing during this, we'll have lots of cramping. Is there a binder I need to take?
Or is there a protocol I'm doing in taking care of detoxing all of this? So if you're if you are
passing parasites due to taking an iron back to the infant bed as well, you don't need a binder.
You won't absorb those things. So a binder is in terms of a nutritional binder that this person
is talking about is is something that will grab onto stuff in the cold. So it's a supplement that
you take like activated charcoal or some sodium alginate, bentonite clay. These are all different
binders that will just grab onto things in the gut. Typically binders by definition, you don't absorb
them. They stay in the gut, grabs onto things in the gutter just holds onto them so that you don't
reabsorb things. You're killing parasites. You don't need to worry about that. You won't
it reabsorb parasites. It wasn't to absorb anyhow. So it was a living organism that you're killing
and your toxins don't have any organisms. So no, you don't need to do that. You don't really need any
other help detoxing. The only thing that I would say is go back to my seven days of detox book if
you're constipated or something like that. That could be an issue when you want to help with that.
No, you don't need anything like that. So that is a good thing. I would say though with the picture
that you sent me, I would pulse these two things if it was me, meaning that I would take a break
for a while. Maybe go off a week and then go back on go week by week. So understand that concept
everybody. And we do have an article pretty sure about what that means when I say the word pulse.
So when you pulse a supplement, you are giving it a break. So pulse or pulsing supplements
would be going like let's say you've been taking something daily for a period of time.
And there can be a good idea on taking a break. Like dropping it down to
you know taking a weekend off. So you're on five days on and then two days on.
That there's nothing wrong with doing that. There's nothing wrong with especially with like
hyperbectic appendix all going off a week and going back out again. Just giving your body a little
bit of a break to kind of reset. That's what pulsing supplements pulsing. You would do that with the
prescription medication, but you could do that with something that you're taking for more supplemental
and hyperbectic appendix all fall into that kind of way too. Why does the room smell different when
the right phone is on. I think it's smelly like ozone does the machine create ozone that's
depleted oxygen doesn't really. The answer is yes, the right machine does create ozone really mainly
if you have the QX2 bond. You're really not going to create ozone with the
with the regular the bulb that you guys have the hammer bulb. But if you have the QX2 bulb,
you are creating static electricity with the back plate on it and you will create ozone for oxygen.
You are not going to be depleted oxygen in the room. The level of ozone that you're creating is
minimal. Matter of fact, it's not even really therapeutic. That's because that's not what you're
trying to do. But you will create a little bit of ozone. You'll have a little ozone smell to it.
There's nothing wrong with that. It's not depleted oxygen in the room.
Comment on back to this question. Would I take hyperbectic appendix at the same time or take one that
different days take the other? No, I would, you know, whatever you're doing now go off for, you know,
three, four, five, six, seven days, both of them and then go back on to your to your same
frequency that you want. So give them a break to both of them so that your body can just kind of
reset for both of them. Information on itching skin. You can still search things like that itching
skin on this quite confident. I don't have an article of itching skin. So let's talk about itching
skin. There are certain cancers that do cause. Matter of fact, some people are diagnosed with
cancer because they get super itching. And the reason why that would be is if you have an increase
in bilirubin. So bilirubin is the breakdown of red blood cells and it is excreted through the
bile, through the bile duct. So some cancers can cause an increase in the breakdown of red blood
cells and an increase bilirubin that way. Some other cancers can cause a blockage of the bile duct.
So the most common cause of increased bilirubin, which would cause jaundice and itchiness of the
skin can start with the lower extremities and then upper extremities. I have talked to people who
were diagnosed with lymphoma or leukemia or a bile duct cancer or a pancreatic cancer because they
had this incessive itchiness. They were itching so bad that their legs were bleeding and that's how
they figured out something was wrong with them. That's what brought them to the doctor, went to their
regular GP, did some tests and the cancer was discovered. When a person already has a diagnosis
of cancer, can there be other reasons for itchiness of the skin? Yes, there's lots of other reasons.
So we don't want to think that it's always because of an increased bilirubin. If the person doesn't
have any level of jaundice, their eyes are nice and light, their skin isn't yellowed at all,
then it's quite possible. It has nothing to do with what I just said. You can itchiness of the skin
because of a decreased fat consumption because it's really dry outside or in the middle of the winter,
very cold weather and you need to start taking some coconut oil or something like that, orally.
So there's other possible reasons for itchiness of the skin dehydration is one possible reason.
I'm just going out the top of my head, but you want to dig always to the reason why.
But when you have cancer, you do want to look at could there be a blockage in the bile duct?
Because many cancers can cause a blockage in the bile duct. Even breast cancer, prostate cancer,
any cancer, most most kind of area of a tasticist for any cancer is the liver. And if it happens to
the tasticized right near the common bile duct, it could cause a blockage in the bile duct and that
could increase bilirubin and cause itchiness of the skin. And depending on your tone of your skin color,
you might not notice the jaundice. So you really want to look at the whites of the eyes,
the whites of the eyes are nice and bright and white, and it's maybe not that. It could be so one of
the other possible reasons I talked about, but if your jaundice at all, if you get yellowed in the
whites of the eyes, you definitely want to get into your ecologist and get a scan done of your liver
and bile duct. I've been using the right since January 2020. The left kidney tumor has been growing
slowly from 2.5 to 5 centimeters now. It seems this protocol is not effective. Let me stop right there.
Well, no, I know everybody wants their cancer to disappear and go away. That's why you're trying to
do what you're doing, right? So I don't know the whole mode of this sac comment, but you have to
remember, I mean, maybe if you were doing what you were what you're currently doing, your tumor
could have been completely invasive and taken over your whole body and that's not 5 centimeters. It's
10 centimeters now. You just don't know. So don't discount all the positive things that you've been doing
all the positive energy that you put into healing your cancer and doing, you know, everything you're
doing, whether you're doing standards of care with your ecologist or you're doing alternative things
to me or somebody else, don't discount what you're doing that you're, oh, it's not working because
my tumor doubled in size. Well, it could have maybe would have quadrupled in size. That being said,
okay, what do I do now? Well, that's the question of the day. You could try some different protocols,
you could try some different things. I know this person has tried a lot of different things,
but it's doing a lot of things currently. You do have to think about using some
standards of care. So I know this person is because their answer to their question right here
is surgery possible. I think, yeah, you do need to talk to a surgeon and get some opinions. Again,
with everything, you want to pray about it, make sure you feel a lot of peace about that, about the
decision and sometimes people will go, why do you still know? Why do you still know? Well, go
slow down. Make the decision. You don't have to make the decision tomorrow. Go slow. Talk to some
surgeons. Meet with them. Schedule some appointments. Let God open up the door for you and you will
feel that it's the right thing to do when it gets to that point, but sometimes we've got a step
to the river before he parks the water. And that's okay. So just take the initial steps, make an
appointment with a surgeon or a oncologist and take those initial steps and you'll know if
the door closes and you're like, I know that's not what I'm supposed to do. I do not feel good about this.
Or I feel good about this, but I don't feel good about this person. I want to go with a different
surgery. Go step by step, step by step. Okay, long question here. I see that the Founder's
Clinic website states that you're no longer practicing. Yes, our website states that I am no longer
practicing because legally, you know, I've never practiced. I was never practicing, but that's one
of the things the board is coming up against us and other people about is that we're practicing.
So I had to put that on the website that we're not practicing. Okay, so that's that. So it's just
everything that we've been talking about. This person has been on the Zoom calls, but just go back
to what we were talking about way back here about just the different changes of the laws started in November
that and that really affected us, you know, with this final rule, the state of Minnesota and December
that we just have to really keep everything to the Zoom calls. Are there two subs? Are these two
subs okay for me? Resveratrol and decaf mega green tea extract by life is still a big extension.
Well, they're not going to get a drink. So the answer to this is those two products, those two nutrients
are totally good for you. Life extensions, Resveratrol is just fine. That's what you have in
home of the cupboard. That's just fine. Life extensions decaf mega green tea extract is is not
a superior product. That's a very inferior product in my opinion. I said over and over that green tea
extract is the most tainted nutrient on the market of all supplements that exist.
There's only a few companies that I would recommend that you get your green tea extract from and the
number one company is the US enzymes brand that's called TVGO. So TVGO from US enzymes is the far superior
green tea extract. They are the most anal company and testing their green tea extracts. I've visited
their factory multiple times. They are the most pure of all the products out there. US enzymes
cross the border are the most pure products of any supplement company. And green tea extract is
the thing that you have to be the most careful about. Number three, oncologist said I could probably
have a low back to me instead of a mastectomy. Well, that is fantastic news. I hope the surgeon
agrees. Well, again, if that, if you don't feel comfortable about the surgeon, if they don't agree
with that, you can find another surgeon and talk to somebody else. That's going to January,
when we pray in for you about that. By remaining two or as pretty superficial now, this person did send
me a picture. So it's just a pea size. Should I do black sap again? After looking at the picture,
I personally wouldn't. I would wait and do and have your surgical consults and see what they,
I just can't imagine that they wouldn't do the low back to me. I just can't imagine after
looking at it. So I mean, it's so easy that I don't think that any surgeon is going to have an issue
with it. Number five, is it safe to leave the lip builds in after they've had cancer in them?
It depends on who you talk to. So the oncologists in surgeon, they're going to always err on the safer
quote, and they're by the safer side. There is radical. The term is radical surgery, radical,
mastectomy, radical, because it is radical. Meaning they're taking way more than they probably should.
And they think that's a good thing. So you have to find a conservative surgeon that will work with them.
The oncologist says, I have a 25% chance of getting lymphedema if I get five to seven lip builds out.
How could I save my lip builds? I will say that it's some, I don't know where he pulled that number,
he or she pulled that number out of. Because I don't think there's any really statistics on that.
And I've seen at least. But I do think there's a varied degree of lymphedema that people get.
We've had number of levers that have had 30 to 50 lip builds removed and don't have any lymphedema.
And we've had people that just have percentile lip don't removed and they have some lymphedema
typically not much. It's usually people that get a lot of lip builds removed that have a greater
degree of lipidema. So how could you save your lip builds? That's a discussion you need to have
with your surgeon. They're going to want to air out the safer side again according to how they
describe that. But you'll have to talk to your surgeon. You are going to give them consent when
you sign that consent form that they can do whatever they think is professional once it gets you under
that eye. That's the sad thing. So you got to make sure you really trust your surgeon.
Is there any point in doing thermography at this point? I really don't think so. You already know
what you're dealing with. I don't think there's a need to do thermography unless you just want to get
kind of a baseline before your surgery. Then you can't do it. You have to give yourself at least three
months after the surgery for things to calm down to another one. But that would be the only thing.
I mean, they're cheap and it's in some completely not invasive. So I don't think there's anything
all looked at them. So that's where no longer to get cheek swabs. How do we know which supplements to add
if any from your new core cause and the members side? I would do it. First of all, you can ask
questions out here. But I wouldn't change any thing if you're doing well. I mean, that's the whole
thing. You don't change things that don't work. You don't fix something that's not broken. So
if you are doing well, then I would just stay on doing what you're doing. It's things have turned
for the worse if you're not doing well, then you have to make some changes. That's where you make
some changes to your protocol. So I think that's your guideline is how well you're doing. How long
before we start seeing weight gain? This is a person that has some cakexia and they are trying to
gain weight. Yeah, that's difficult. You know, cakexia is statistically one of the hardest things to
deal with with later stage cancer from anybody's perspective, natural or standards of care. There's
just not really anything that you can do, but you've got to start eating some carbohydrates.
So if you could just call the weight loss down, you're waiting. So the person's losing three to four
pounds a week, no matter what they're eating, and then now their weight has kind of stabilized,
whether or not losing any weight anymore, you are waiting. So just keep doing what you can do,
keep trying to get calories in, and you have to be eating complex carbohydrates.
By two more blood on Monday, and I couldn't stop it, we went to the ER and still at the hospital.
This person, I hope you saw the questions that we answered last week. I am starting my first
radiation treatment this afternoon. Oh, that is fantastic. That is great. Glad to hear that.
They are suggesting radiation and chemo together. What are your thoughts about chemo?
You really want to talk to the oncologists and say, okay, well, I know you want me to do chemo,
how was that going to give me any better chance? There's nothing wrong with pinpointing them down.
They won't let us give any statistics because there are the gods that have all the statistics.
Well, then pass them the statistics. How do you think this is going to actually improve my life?
Is this going to, you're saying this, if I do chemo, you're going to give me another month to live,
but I'm going to live a horrific existence for that month because I'm going to be so sick.
So just ask them those pin-pointed questions. They're the ones asking you to do something that's
going to make you sick. So you have the right to ask them those questions.
I just got my tumor marker back six weeks ago. It was 389 yesterday. It was 172 super, super excited.
Thanks for everything you do for me. Well, I'm praise God for that. Thank you. We use the one
of the regeals. That is fantastic news. We've just made my day in Karen and I'll leave that.
I heard that co-cutan recycled glutathione prevents apoptosis. Do you agree? It's true
by some spectrum as co-cutanative. Should I stop? Should I be taking something else?
So I don't agree. And I don't agree that recycling glutathione prevents apoptosis.
Your glutathione will recycle the glutathione. That's how you glutathione is oxidized and then
reduced. That's the recycling process of glutathione that happens in every cell.
And there isn't anything wrong with cancer patients taking glutathione. The argument with cancer
patients taking glutathione is, first of all, I don't think there's anything wrong with cancer patients
taking co-cutanative. There isn't argument about cancer patients taking glutathione because they say
that, oh, it'll help, you know, it helps increase the metabolic process and help heal the mitochondria
of the cell. That's why you would take glutathione. It's a strong antioxidant. It's the number one
intracellular antioxidant. So if a person is doing chemotherapy, I would agree. It's probably not
a good idea to be doing glutathione, taking glutathione, if you're doing chemotherapy.
Same the reason why you would do antioxidants like alphalopeic acid or vitamin C
while you're doing chemotherapy. But if you're done with chemotherapy or you're beyond 48 hours after
chemotherapy, chemotherapy infusion, you know, I don't see any harm in trying to protect your healthy
cells by giving them the ability to detoxify a poison. That's what an antioxidant does. That's
what glutathione does for yourself. A protein I use or gain plant protein. Could this be my tumor?
Yes, it could. So this person has a pancreatic tumor that does feed off of animal proteins, but
any protein could feed the tumor. So there's a question really and why would you want to take protein?
Why do you want to take a protein powder? If a person is just constantly fatigued, their energy
just isn't the pits. They are taking five, six, naps a day. They just can't seem to do anything.
They have no drive in life. That can be a protein deficiency and that can be a reason why you may
want to add some protein. If a person, make sure you don't make a mistake that I am losing weight.
So I need to eat protein. Eating protein is not going to help a person from losing
with a weight loss issue. Protein does not make you gain weight, kind of a hydrants gain weight,
you gain weight. So for a cancer patient to feel like they need to be taking a protein powder,
I question that. But the right protein powder to take if you're going to, would be a plant-based
protein. So but the question is why are you taking it? So if it is like your fatigue is so bad
and you feel like you have lost muscle mass and you just don't have any energy and drive in life,
then by all means you can take that, that would be the right type of protein to take as a plant-based
protein. But if you're not having those issues, I would just drop that. I answered that one.
Sorry if you covered this earlier. I joined late. Is there any way now to get an updated
kinesiology testing, but kinetic testing? No, we can't do that legally. So we can't do any testing
legally. You can do it from a local chiropractor or something, but we can't do any kinesiology testing.
Legally, that's a thing that they're just shutting down any clinics from doing anything
in any state that you're not licensed in to do that thing. And we're not licensed in any state
to do kinesiology testing. It's just insane. I hate to say this. It's getting worse. Did you know that
just passed a law in California that started January 1st? Any licensed medical doctor in California
could go longer? State any opinions about health publicly? So they can't, let's say if you're a
medical doctor in California, licensed in California, and you, let's say, broken apart from the
established enthusiasm of the the pharma medical system and you started your own little practice
and you're teaching people about omega-3 fatty acids and you have a video out about omega-3 fatty acids
you're breaking them all. That's insane. You can't give any medical opinions publicly. You can't say,
hey, I don't think the vaccines are good for you or you can't say, hey, I don't think that you should
be eating too much sugar. Then you are breaking the law in California and they can pull your license.
That's absolutely insane. This is what they're well-to-sweeted across the country so that they
can control everything. In my last checkup, the oncologist stated, my tuber is still stable,
but what am I done? Jules has grown. Not sure how that works. Question. Since fighting this out,
I decided to get back chemo, along with the four COC drugs, that's the carol-college drugs,
and all of the cutters protocol for chemo. Since the addition of the carol-college drugs,
should I be doing anything else and putting another cheek swab? We can't do cheek swabs anymore.
I would get back on the protocol that we had you on. My question would be, is it your oncologist
that was really pushing you to get back on the tool? That was just your choice. Certainly, if it's your
choice, I would just follow our protocol that we had you on the floor. Suggestions have
identified a dentist that are more natural and polyopathic. Look for a biological dentist.
So you can search Google Biological Dentist near me and then look at their website and you'll see,
you know, they use mercury fillings. Do they have a mercury vacuum to remove fillings? Do they have
information on their website about the dangers of mercury fillings and how to get them removed
naturally? And then that'll give you a lot of clues that that person is naturally minded.
So I personally go to a dentist that I wouldn't say he's a biological dentist, but we had
our two youngest children to him. We've been going to him for years. And we said, we don't want
mercury fillings. That was the first time we went to him. This was on a couple of days and years ago.
And he said, oh, never done that. Why would you put something in somebody's mouth that I have to put in a,
you know, a sharps container and haven't disposed of in a way that's not dangerous to the environment,
does make any sense. So somebody posted green smoothiegirl.com has a nationwide guide.
That's something to look at. I understand a lot of dentists are in any of these nationwide guides.
There's more and more local dentists that are anti, you know, some of their established dentistry
things. So it's much easier to find some of the unit tips to have, go to somebody that's like
perfectly down the path. But you want to go to somebody if you're going to have mercury removed,
you have to have them done the right way with the mercury vacuum with the dam put in with them.
You know, what he did good healthy fillings of doing things correctly. And a lot of dentists do that.
A lot of people are going to go to that. So thank you for the info about green smoothie girl.
We have other questions. Okay. Well, thank you guys for being on and keep your questions really
good. We had some good questions. I'm not sure where to turn if there are no cheek spots.
Now we have all our extended protocols. I'll end up the member site. So make sure you get to the
member site. Look at the extended expanded protocols. If you're having troubles and things are going
to arrive with you, then just ask those questions on the zoom. You know, hey, my cancer's growing really
bad. What should I do? I pull up your file and we can go over on the zoom call. We can do a lot of,
we can do anything we want on a group. And it's and I get it. If you're asking a question on the
chat and everybody can see your name and you go like that. That's why I asked the question like,
you know, this person did. They said this question in on the member site.
And so this person, they sent me their information, sent a question in the member site. It's legal
for me to talk about them specifically on a group zoom call because it's all educational. We're
educating in group. That's the legality of it. Is it ridiculous? Yes. Is it criminal? I think,
yeah, I think it is. It's a sec that we have to do things this way and that they're
think that they can control what you can receive by your own volition. But you know, this is what we
got to do. So ask the question. So now it's anonymous. This person, nobody knows who this person is,
for me. So should I hold off on coffee? In a sense, these make them leading worse the pair,
cut the pair of sites. Yeah, I would too. I'd, I'd pause that as well. And, and pulse that as well.
You know, you do it so well in so many other ways. It's just pulse that maybe just pause coffee
anonymous for a period of time. So, you know, understand. I mean, I, I don't do coffee anonymous anymore.
I mean, I did a couple months ago. I did several days in a row and months before that. But
then I probably went six months without doing a coffee in a month. So it's, you know, I just,
you know, I feel like I've been remissioned. So I'm just, you know, I just, I don't do them on a regular
basis. I didn't do them on a very regular basis. So sick. I thought I was going to die. So I, you know,
there's nothing wrong with pulse seed things like coffee anonymous. I haven't had a sauna for a while.
What's going to do on today? But you don't want to make your treatment, your God. And you,
you want to, you're doing this treatment to go better, leave your life, enjoy your life, follow
what God has for you, and then the next things are, you know, seem to turn for the worse again.
They get back on your protocols and do what you're supposed to do and trust God for the answers
again. All right. Keep the questions coming in. And we'll see you guys next Wednesday. Again,
and let us know. Let me know on the question blue question box on the member site if you want to
do a protocol, zoom call, maybe do it once a month or something. Let me know. All right.
Love you all. Pray for you all. Love I don't